[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Anthony Bourdain's ex-wife breaks her  social-media silence on the famed chefs  death Ottavia Busia Bourdain who was  married to the TV personality from 2007  to 2016 took to Instagram to share this  sweet message about their 11 year old  daughter  Arianne our little girl had her concert  today she was amazing so strong and  brave she wore the boots you bought her  I hope you are having a good trip  wherever you are  Bourdain was found dead of an apparent  suicide in a French hotel room Friday  morning by his friend and fellow chef  Eric repair in a phone interview with  NBC News his mother Gladys Bourdain  revealed she last heard from her son in  an email on mother's day adding that  there was never any sign that something  was wrong  he didn't disguise anything he was who  he was and it was out there for everyone  to see Gladys a former editor at The New  York Times shared that she'll remember  her son as a lover of people of all  kinds  [Music]  you